trente ans déjà et pas une ride
la confrérie des gastronomes normand a
fêté l'événement dans le respect de la
tradition en invitant 24 confréries
françaises et étrangères qui ont ajouté
aux fastes grand maître et jura remparts
et majorettes sonneurs et curieux
travers certain si lentement la ville de
caen entre le château et l'esplanade
jean marie nouvelle à pied ou sur des
landaus tirées par les chevaux voire à
bord de vieux tacots rutilant en
profitait de l'occasion pour introniser
50 nouveaux palais dans l'ordre de la
tripière d'or au terme de cette journée
de samedi
cinq auteurs de raisin ou de groseille
l'amateur de bouddha ou l'embrouillé
connaisseur du trou normand des
dégustateurs de suisse de fenouil sans
oublier défenseur de l'africa test vous
les grands maîtres c'est hélas et de
l'avis de certains rares ont été les
anniversaires réunir autant de concret
si ce 30e anniversaire a donc été fêté
comme il se doit et de dimanche la salle
et prochaine de trois heures pour tout
free l'anniversaire se terminer devant
un buffet campagnard au son d'un concert
il reste que pour les organisateurs
sacrifié à la tradition n'a rien cédé ni
rien et dépassant 90
une confrérie qui depuis trente ans ont
manifesté pour améliorer la qualité de
la trique et alors j'ai un défilé d'une
correction est gentillet et amicale
c'est surtout ça et c'est pourquoi je
trouve ça très bien
certes il est amusant de voir des
voitures à cheval mais ne pensez vous
pas qu'à l'heure actuelle c'est à chacun
est heureux d'avoir un barbecue une
maison à la campagne
et quand il le peut pouvoir monter à
cheval ne croyez-vous pas que tout à
chacun est heureux d essayer de
retrouver un passé qui hélas sans mât
plus en plus chaque jour